Donald Trump Junior appeared on the Ingram angle
on Fox News on Thursday night where he made the
absurd, ridiculous, immoral, disgusting claim that
Corona virus deaths are almost nothing. A thousand
people died in the United States of Corona virus
on that day. And he is on Fox News saying these
idiot liberals won't tell you that deaths are
almost nothing. And by the way, if you want
to learn more about his data, you can check his
Instagram. I'm not kidding. Take a look at this.
These people, these people are truly morons.
You don't mean that. I like how they go after
Scott Atlas because he's not an epidemiologist.
But Sanjay Gupta now magically is. I mean, give
me a break, Laura. The reality is this. If you
look I put it up on my Instagram a couple of days
ago because I went through the CDC that I kept
hearing about new infections, but I was like,
well, why are they talking about this? Oh, oh,
because the number is almost nothing, because
we've gotten control of this. We understand how
to how it works. They have the therapeutics to
be able to deal with this. If you look at that,
look at my Instagram, it's gotten almost nothing.
Right. Right. Donald Trump Junior's Instagram is
the top place for health news. Don is analyzing
health data on his Instagram page if you
want to follow him there. The deaths are
almost nothing. We've had more than 700 deaths per
the Stanford study just because of 18 of Donald
Trump's rallies. We had a thousand dead on the
day. Don Junior said deaths are almost nothing.
We had another 900 dead the day after. Don
Junior said deaths are almost nothing. There
were another thousand dead the day before.
Don Junior said deaths are almost nothing.
And another thousand the day before that. These
people, aside from being liars and debasing truth,
they've debased the value of human life.
When a thousand people per day are dying
and they say, we did it, we're rounding the turn.
We're doing great. Deaths are almost nothing.
You're actually devaluing human life.
They claim to be pro-life people.
They say the reason the
reason we're against abortion
is we value human life above everything else.
Well, apparently, they don't value human life
above stock market, having a grocery store,
allowing full capacity rather than partial
schools, et cetera, et cetera. These are
the understand the backwards nature of what
we're seeing. If you ask people what is most
important to you? A lot of these folks say
life. Human life is sacred. Even at the
Zae God stage. And then a thousand people
die. And then another thousand. And then another
thousand. And they say deaths are almost nothing
in reality. Reelection is the most valuable thing
to them. Way more valuable than life. And the
stock market. Yes, for sure. And by the way, you
know, I guess this is a good moment to insert some
facts about therapeutics. Says UDR therapeutics
are just absolutely fantastic. I would speak
over the weekend. I spoke to an E.R. doctor
friend of mine. And during the big spike we
had in Massachusetts, remember, they're a
place we're in our third spike in the U.S.,
but there are places that we're able to avoid
a second spike. Massachusetts was one of them
during the initial spike in Massachusetts. This
friend was moved from the E.R. to a covered floor
and he might have to go back there in a few weeks
due to the spike that is now being experienced.
He said we really don't have good therapeutics at
this point. It's actually remarkable how we still
don't have good therapeutics. Hydroxy chloroquine
was obviously a bust, Fox News pretends like they
never even mentioned it anymore. Room, desk, sivir
more recently. It doesn't really seem to have even
the modest functioning that we thought it did from
early studies. The dexamethasone does seem to help
some patients, and that's good. That's really
a general thing. Anytime you have inflammation.
Doctors would guess if you give a
steroid, you can reduce inflammation,
ideally to put the body in a better state to fight
off the virus and heal itself. It's not anything
particular about this virus. That's a general
medical principle. And so what this doctor was
telling me is we really don't have particularly
good functioning therapeutics at this point. Now,
thankfully, because we managed for a period
of time to reduce hospitalizations so that
the hospitals were less full. That's reversing.
But for a while, hospitals were less full. We
have better protocols in terms of Ja's being able
to recognize the stage of disease. Who needs the
decks? Who needs a ventilator? Who needs oxygen?
Thanks to that and the hospitals being less full,
we've reduced the mortality rate. It also does
seem like when you're spending more time outdoors
than indoors, when you do catch it, you're
ideally catching it with a lower viral load,
which seems to correlate with a less
serious case. OK, all of that stuff.
But the therapeutics, we really aren't doing great
on, even the monoclonal antibody data is not great
from what we've seen so far. So Don Junior is
wrong about everything. He's wrong. Morally,
he's wrong. Factually, he's wrong statistically.
And of course, he's wrong in that they value
life above all else. Just look at
the way that they've been behaving